who did the most research on their  character well scarlett has done the  most research and that she's played  character natasha romanov multiple times  before so she has put in a lot of work  into the character most likely to break  during a scene  me okay most likely to pull pranks on  set i think the prize for that would  definitely go to mr david harbour david  harbour is a kind of living embodiment  of prankiness who is most like their  character i don't think any of us are  like our characters i think we're all  acting characters that are like  superheroes and who's like that in real  life no one right who is the least like  their character  i am nothing like my character melina  i'm immensely fond of her i had to  journey like  a long way to be her yeah which is great  it's very fun to play a character that's  not like you most likely to actually be  a spy  i mean i couldn't possibly tell you  right  [Applause]  [Music]  you